well I think it's important to recognize
that in starting in the middle part of
the nineteenth century the world economy
became increasingly integrated we tend
to think today and take for granted the
notion that the world economy is very
tightly globalised that is that Goods
capital and even people ideas technology
flow around the world very easily from
place to place we take that for granted
and we tend to think that that's the
natural and normal course of affairs the
fact is that the world has been here
before that is one hundred hundred and
fifty hundred and seventy years ago
starting in the 1840s and all the way up
until 1914 the world was generally
speaking at least as globalized
economically as it is today Capital
moved around the world in vast
quantities trade was roughly as
integrated as it is today flows of
people were even higher and even higher
levels than they are today that is you
could move around the world in the 19th
and early 20th century pretty much
without papers any European who wanted
to leave his homeland that moved to the
new world at a Latin America to
Australia could do so without a passport
without documents to show up and as long
as you weren't insane or an anarchist or
had some terrible communicable disease
you would get in so movements of goods
capital people were very very free 150
years ago in fact the world was tied
together on one dimension even more than
it is today on a monetary standard
called the gold standard or all of the
major world economies shared in a sense
of common currency that is gold you
could go around the world with gold
coins in your pocket and spend them in
virtually every major economy in the
world so we've been here before there
was a world economy that was very
tightly integrated and it lasted for
decades and even generations from the
middle part of the 19th century up until
1914 it all at the time it worked
extraordinarily well on many dimensions
the economy grew faster than it ever had
in those 75 or so years the world
economy grew more and it had in the
previous 1,000 poor countries caught up
with middle-income countries
middle-income countries caught up with
rich countries
country like argentina which is
started off that experience as a sort of
a rural backwater in South America ended
up at the turn of the 20th century one
hundred and so years ago the fifth
wealth wealthiest country in the world
so this was a period in which there was
very rapid rates of economic growth a
lot of convergence as countries became
closer and closer to each other
economically I and a great deal of
macroeconomic stability so the people at
the time like us today could probably be
forgiven for thinking that it was in
fact the natural and normal course of
the fare ISM would go on forever but it
didn't it all came crashing down in a
matter of weeks in 1914 now that was
World War one and people at the time
could be forgiven I suppose for thinking
that it was the wartime experiences in
the wartime dislocations that had led to
the collapse of the globalized world
economy of the 19th and early 20th
century but it wasn't because after the
war ended the world spent the leaders of
the world's major countries spent the
next 20 years trying to put that
classical integrated global economy back
together and they failed over and over
and over again the result of which was
the Great Depression of the 1930s the
rise of fascism fascism and Nazism and
eventually a descent into depression and
war so we have experienced a globalized
world economy before it had a lot of
successes but it also ended in a
spectacular catastrophe and I think we
have perhaps lessons to learn from both
the positive and the negative
experiences of the previous era of
globalization
you